so how do we fight back against this is
really the question because as i say i
think everybody feels it
by the way i think the people who are
who are even kind of mainstream liberals
feel this the reason that i know this is
that there are polls talking about how
many people
are afraid to speak up how many people
feel the pressure
not to say what they think and the
answer is an awful lot of them in fact
the only subgroup of americans who
believe that they get to say what they
believe on a regular basis are people
who consider themselves progressive
that is that is the only group of people
in america by polling
who feel that they get to say what they
believe so how do we fight back against
this
well first of all we're gonna have to
rely on people believe it or not who are
moderate liberals who are sick
of watching the overton window shut now
at the beginning it's gonna be
self-preservation it's gonna be like
that harper's weekly letter that you saw
earlier this year where a bunch of
anti-trump liberals signed a letter
saying we don't like cancel culture
i was like you know what've been nice is
if you had actually defended people who
you disagree with
not just you agreeing with yourself and
saying that you wish that you hadn't
been canceled
it'd be really nice if you opened up the
overton window a little bit wider
you're gonna have to rely on moderate
liberals but i think that coalition is
building
i think the backlash is building i think
that there is a there is there is now
cultural energy
behind the idea that there has to be
some sort of alternative here
and so there are a few things that we
can do right there there are a few
things that i think are actually pretty
necessary here to fight back and i think
that this is going to be the battle for
the next year
as people get thrown off of social media
as
the as social media gets hijacked by a
biden administration
as biden attempts to use the power of
government to cram down his own
particular
woke viewpoint and i know that he isn't
by nature well
he has adopted woke ism as his own okay
as this happens they're gonna be a few
things that have to happen one
conservatives are gonna have to take a
page from trump not in terms of
tweeting whatever trump tweets but you
have to embrace
truth and not niceness i know there are
a lot of conservatives out there who are
worried that if you speak truth it is
not nice
it's one of the reasons why my slogan
has been for years now facts don't care
about your feelings
that actually was something that came up
in the midst of a discussion about what
sort of pronouns to use with people
and i was pointing out that biological
males are biologically male and somebody
said well you have to respect the
pronouns and i said well facts don't
care about your feelings
okay well facts do not care about your
feelings and we're gonna all have to
push forward with that attitude because
it is niceness that has been the chief
weapon
used against the right i think the right
knows this by the way it's why the right
is never going to nominate
a john mccain remember mitt romney again
those days are over there's going to be
no more of this
civil this sort of civil concession
to the language of the left there's not
going to be any more premise accepting
from the right i think that is one of
the legacies that trump has had
but i think that that was going to
happen almost regardless it's why ted
cruz came in second right
so the fact is that niceness is going to
be rejected
in favor of standing up in favor of
virtue and here's the thing standing up
in favor of virtue
is not mean it is just truth standing up
does not mean that you are a jerk it
means that you are saying things that
are true and necessary
okay also you're gonna have to engage
and convince right this is something
that we have not yet done
this means we do have to reach out to
people who are in the middle we do have
to reach out to suburban women who
turned away from trump in this last
election cycle we are going to have to
reach out
not just to to people who already agree
with us but increasingly we're gonna
have to reach out with a conservative
message that speaks truth boldly
and and draws in stark colors to to
people who have not historically voted
republican
by the way that has effect right trump
won and outside the number of hispanics
in the last election
cycle contrary to all previous opinion
he did really well
in texas with hispanics he did really
well in florida with hispanics
he won an outside share of the black
vote right as alienating as trump can be
speaking truth bluntly sometimes has an
effect
and even if you say well yeah trump
didn't always speak truth right trump
said things that are false
i agree with you he said a lot of things
that are false but the underlying
message which is that the institutions
suck and are attempting to drag you into
their own ideology
he was not wrong about that and i think
everybody sort of got that right selena
zito had this formulation
early on in trump's in campaign where
they said people take trump
seriously but not literally and i think
that that has always been true i think
it will remain true because the serious
message underneath all of this
is that this stuff has to stop that the
assault has to stop
okay there's another tactic that the
right is gonna have to take
and this is a tactic i don't
particularly like but i think that we
are reaching that point
okay it's something that i myself pushed
when i was the head of an organization
called truth revolt
my my business partner jeremy boring and
i before we ever launched daily wire
we were we launched a mission that was
sort of reverse media matters the idea
and we said it clearly was mutually
assured destruction
because here's the thing if you can
renormalize an organization
as large as google simply by cobbling
together a coalition of the supposedly
dispossessed
in order to renormalize from the inside
and you can exercise pressure from the
institutions like the media from the
outside
in order to move institutions if you can
threaten boycotts if you can threaten
bad publicity from one side and move the
institution
the right has a choice we can either set
it out and we can
and we can let the left do that or we
can fight back on the left's terms
and that means that if we see a company
that is now pushing leftism
we're gonna have to use the same means
as the left not because we like those
means
i don't like those means i wish we
didn't have to do that but just like
with mutually assured destruction
where everybody wishes nuclear weapons
didn't exist the only thing worse
than you're the only thing worse than
you having nuclear weapons and your
opponents having nuclear weapons is your
opponents having nuclear weapons and you
not having nuclear weapons right
mutually assured destruction
kept the peace the reason it kept the
peace is because everybody knew it had
to be weapons down
otherwise everything would go up in
flames the right is gonna in some ways
have to become more militant not less
militant militants on behalf of
principal okay not on behalf of
personality
not on behalf of just yelling at people
but on behalf of principle
when corporations start cramming down
rob and d'angelo diversity classes
people inside the organization are going
to have to say no and they're going to
have to unify to say no
and this is really the key point beyond
everything else okay beyond everything
else there's going to have to be some
level of solidarity that's built up
it is not fair to ask individuals who
are inside institutions to stand up
as i said before the ratio is a thousand
to one against you you standing up just
gets you fired
we're gonna need to start coalition
building we're gonna need to start
building
communities of people who are willing to
come out together and say no we are not
going along with this
no we are simply not going to do this
and we need to provide
safe haven for people who do get fired
from these sorts of positions
we need to provide defense mechanisms
for people who stand up and get clubbed
on the head
and that means the building of
alternative institutions that means we
need
an alternative media for people who are
ousted from traditional media for
speaking the truth
it means that we need an alternative
hollywood structure where people in
hollywood who disagree with the
prevailing wokism of hollywood
have a place to go and get their movies
funded and we need to patronize those
movies we need to make sure that people
actually watch that stuff
we need to make sure that if you are in
the scientific establishment and you are
out
and you are ousted for the grave sin of
saying something biologically true
that we provide a soft landing for you
that we provide a landing spot for you
and one one of the great mistakes that
the wright made is that they always
assumed that
institutions beyond college would shape
the people coming out of college
right college we understood that
colleges shape the students
and they shape them toward woke
philosophy but we also assumed that they
would get out in the real world they'd
go work in corporate land they would get
a job they'd pay taxes and eventually
they'd get more conservative
and there was some truth to that but
statistically speaking what has now
happened here
is that people exited college and
instead of the institutions shaping them
they shaped the institutions and then by
grabbing power at the institutions
they use the institutions to create
widgets of themselves
to silence everybody there is a majority
in this country that still believes that
america is the greatest country ever
conceived there's still a majority in
this country
that believes that america is not
systemically racist and is filled with
good people who want to treat each other
decently
that still believe in human virtue and
believe in individual rights
there's still a majority in this country
who's willing to go out and work hard
every day and believes
that that work is good for the soul in
many cases and that we shouldn't be
incentivizing people to stay home
there's still a majority of people in
this country who basically want to be
left alone
and most of all there's a majority in
this country that still wants to stick
together but in order for us to
stick together we're actually going to
have to now create structures for us to
stick together
because as benjamin franklin said it
about at the at the outset
of this entire project either we uh hang
together or we hang separately
that is where things currently stand so
we got to make the choice ourselves
right now this next year is going gonna
be the test are we gonna hang together
or are we gonna hang separately
it's easy to splinter in the face of
overwhelming pressure
when things look bad when the white
house moves to the democratic party it's
easy to get discouraged
don't get discouraged get to fighting
because next year is going to be the
fight
the fight didn't start with trump it
didn't end with trump it's going to
continue now
and as the left pushes harder and harder
that just means the right is going to
have to come up with better strategies
and push back harder
in every arena not just with regard to
voting but with regard to every cultural
institution there is we're gonna have to
push back
we're gonna have to push back hard and
if we do i think that we're still the
majority and i think that we'll win
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content